in the seal teams there's no training of
how to report your chief for war crimes
there's no way that i can live with
myself had i not gone forward and
said what i saw
i'm willing to put my life in danger to
get the job done
[Music]
he came over the radio there was a
wounded prisoner eddie said nobody touch
him he's all mine
did you actually see it happen yeah
that's what happened
this is the most disgraceful day i've
ever seen in my life i thought i was
gonna be in trouble just for being there
did you ever intentionally shoot any
unarmed civilian
no
did you ever try to kill an unarmed
teenage boy no
do you remember ever shooting a little
girl
no
it's a very rare occurrence that seals
are going against one of their own
there is a huge mistake going on here
everyone was covering their tail from
the top down
the debate wasn't did eddie kill
prisoner the debate was eddie killed the
prisoner but is that okay they have no
evidence
no proof
every man woman and child that came into
his line of sight he tried to kill him
no that didn't happen
[Music]
you're making it up i hate eddie but
what you're doing is lying
i should not be on trial for murder it
is war
i don't think they were prepared for
this giant bombshell in the courtroom
i'm innocent i love you bye sweetheart
there's a line in the sand now
unfortunately the truth is not perfect
you